[Música]
Bienvenidos a esta entrevista desde la
feria del libro de Buenos Aires en
France 24 nos acompaña una escritora y
filóloga española autora de un éxito de
ventas pero sobre todo un éxito de
lectura que es el infinito en un Junco
un libro que cuenta una parte muy
importante de la historia de la
escritura y de los libros Irene Vallejo
Muchas gracias No gracias por la
invitación hay una cita del libro que es
cuando comparamos hay muchas citas yo lo
tengo todo marcado
cuando comparamos algo viejo y algo
nuevo dice como un libro y una tableta o
una monja sentada junto a una de las
adolescentes que chatea en el metro
creemos que lo nuevo tiene más futuro y
en realidad sucede lo contrario Cuanto
más años lleva un objeto o una costumbre
entre nosotros más por venir tiene están
apareciendo ahora cosas muy nuevas para
nosotros como las tecnologías de
generación automática de textos o
algunos hablan de Inteligencia
artificial no sé si es el término
correcto
Cómo se pueden encuadrar estas nuevas
tecnologías de la palabra
en toda esta historia son un episodio de
un de una larga historia no pero sí me
gusta destacar que los libros
tradicionales Probablemente van a seguir
vivos
coexistiendo con los nuevos inventos y
las nuevas modulaciones de esta larga
historia de creación de afán por conocer
por crear por escuchar historias no y me
importa subrayar que todo aquello que
viene de muy antiguo y ha sobrevivido
milenios tiene una fuerza acumulada no
una trayectoria reconocida de
supervivencia que
probablemente le da el pasaporte hacia
el futuro con mucha más claridad que
todas estas novedades que se van
sucediendo pero que son efímeras en su
duración mientras que los libros
nacieron en una época era importante y
aún podemos leer un manuscrito escrito
en el siglo 11 y sin embargo perdemos
documentos archivos porque las sucesivas
aplicaciones o cambios tecnológicos
hacen imposible acceder a ellas
ha estado ensayando jugando probando
estas tecnologías de generación
automática de textos Sí realmente en
este momento me parecen muy limitadas No
son no son fiables no y creo que quizás
las estamos idealizando demasiado las
estamos deificando y pensando que
incluso van a sustituir a los seres
humanos cuando
la negativa
idealizando su poder y su capacidad y su
impacto pero no creo que nunca podamos
considerar las superiores al producto de
una persona que realmente trabaja con
toda su experiencia con toda su pasión
no sabiduría adquirida y con esas
emociones que nos hacen no realmente
sentir esta conexión que aquí en la
feria del libro vibra entre lectores y
escritores y que es algo tan bello y tan
inimitable y que hace que la gente se
traslade a veces desde larguísimas
distancias para tener ese instante de
cercanía y de mirada con el escritor no
encuentro físico
de los lectores con los libros de los
escritores entre sí de los sectores con
los lectores nos lleva de nuevo a la
idea de lo material y de lo corporal del
cuerpo y la materialidad que están súper
presentes en la obra también
vuelvo un poco a lo que hablábamos de la
generación automática de contenidos no
tienen cuerpo entonces en qué medida la
falta de cuerpo puede tener que ver
con la incapacidad de llegar hasta donde
llega el autor o la creatividad humana
totalmente no muchas veces en los textos
percibes la cicatriz la carne el
sufrimiento la emoción el fervor todo
eso lo transmite la literatura que viene
de seres humanos y además el libro
tradicional es como el cuerpo de las
palabras no y en el infinito en un Junco
Pues voy analizando sobre que materiales
hemos escrito a lo largo de la historia
Cómo se hemos experimentado con el
papiro con el pergamino con el Metal con
la piedra con la arcilla no después con
el papel ahora con la luz no como como
hemos buscado hacer corpóreo este soplo
de aire que son las palabras y que son
nuestros relatos y como esa corporalidad
nos hace sentir un placer especial no
asociado al acariciar la página al que
tenga una dedicatoria personal que haga
único el volumen no el sentir un aroma y
ahora aquí en la feria pues Esa cercanía
no esa sensación de pertenecer todos a
este mismo clan que es el de la lectura
porque En definitiva Somos todos
lectores siempre y creo que que sí que
en este mundo de soledad y de
distanciamiento entre las personas no a
través de esas pantallas frías los
libros crean comunidades y la
efervescencia de los clubes de lectura
lo está demostrando no como la gente se
reúne en torno a los libros como en
otros tiempos alrededor de las hogueras
y querer compartir las palabras quiere
compartir prestar leer en voz alta No
tocarse sentirse y comprobar que
efectivamente los libros son algo muy
humano son el envoltorio el cofre de una
voz que nos apela porque sabemos que
viene de otro ser humano con las mismas
fragilidades que las nuestras
gracias
Y ustedes Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos en esta entrevista de
Francis
[Música]